>> Raymond: EARLIER THIS WEEK
ACTOR MARK WAHLBERG AND HIS
FOUNDATION AND FRIENDS HELPED
RAISE FUNDS FOR KIDS VIA A
CELEBRITY GOLF TOURNAMENT AND I
WAS SLICING ALONG WITH THEM.
>> WHOO!
>> Raymond: A FEW WEEKS AGO I
WAS ASKED TO TAKE PART AS A
GOLFER HERE AT THE MARK WAHLBERG
FOUNDATION AND BEAUMONT
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL FUND-RAISER.
HERE WE ARE AT THE DETROIT GOLF
CLUB.
THERE'S ONLY ONE PROBLEM.
I HAVEN'T TOUCHED A GOLF CLUB
SINCE I WAS 12 YEARS OLD.
MAYBE MY PALS CAN HELP.
>> JIM WAHLBERG RUNS THE MARK
WAHLBERG YOUTH FOUNDATION.
>> TELL ME ABOUT THE WAHLBERG
FOUNDATION.
WHERE DID THIS ORIGINATE AND WHY
THE EMPHASIS ON FOCUS ON YOU.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU FOR
COMING OUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO PRINCIPATE.
RAYMOND DOESN'T GOLF AND HE
STILL CAME OUT AND SAID I'LL DO
MY JERRY LEWIS THING.
I'LL DO WHATEVER I HAVE TO DO TO
SUPPORT.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL AND I APPRECIATE
IT.
THE MARK WAHLBERG FOUNDATION HAS
BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR JUST ABOUT
20 YEARS.
OUR FAMILY PRIEST CAME TO US AND
SAID THE ROOF IS FALLING APART.
IT IS THE CENTERPIECE OF THE
COMMUNITY.
I'M SO WE RAISED THE NECESSARY
FUNDS.
IT'S A MATTER OF RESPONSIBILITY.
YOU ARE A SUCCESSFUL PERSON
WHETHER YOU'RE A MOVIE STAR OR A
NEWS ANCHOR OR A CONSTRUCTION
WORKER.
MY FAMILY, MY MOTHER ALWAYS MADE
IT A POINT TO LET US KNOW THAT
THERE WAS ALWAYS GOING TO BE
SOMEBODY THAT WAS STRUGGLING
BEHIND US AND WE NEEDED TO DO
ALL WE COULD.
>> Raymond: THE ONE OR TWO
THINGS THAT I NEED TO BE MINDFUL
OF?
>> HIT THE BALL.
THE BALL IS SITTING THERE ALL BY
ITSELF.
ALL OF A SUDDEN YOUR NERVES.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE COMPOSED.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE STABLE.
>> Raymond: FOR STABILITY,
SUGAR RAY WORKS THE LINKS THE
WAY HE WORKED THE RING.
>> I KIND OF BREAK THINGS DOWN.
I LOOK AT YOUR WEAK POINTS, YOUR
STRONG POINTS.
FIGURE OUT THE BEST WAY.
FIND A WAY TO BREAK IT DOWN.
>> Raymond: DON'T DO THAT.
DON'T DO THAT.
[AUDIO SLOWED DOWN]
>> DOES IT HURT?
>> Raymond: KNOW IT DOESN'T
HURT.
THIS HAS GOT TO BE ONE OF THE
GREAT HONORS OF MY LIFE, BEING
WITH THE SUGAR RAY LEONARD.
THE SUGAR RAY.
>> I FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE
CALLING THE SUGAR.
YOU SEEM TO BE A BIT ALMOST
THERE BUT NOT THERE.
>> Raymond: I AM NUTRASWEET
RAY COMPARED TO YOU.
DON'T GET THEIR WAY OF THOSE
FISTS.
I DIDN'T REALIZE, BUT I FELT IT.
WARNED ME NEXT TIME.
WARNED ME.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO TAKE CARE OF
YOURSELF.
>> Raymond: EVANDER HOLYFIELD
OFFERED ME SOME ADVICE.
>> PLAY WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
BETTER.
THIS TOURNAMENT.
YOU'RE PLAYING AS A TEEN.
>> Raymond: SURELY ACTOR KEVIN
DOLAN WILL GIVE ME SOME GOLF
TIPS.
YOUR FATHER WAS THE GOLF COACH
AT FORDHAM.
WHAT DID HE TEACH YOU?
>> HE TOLD ME MOSTLY ABOUT THE
MENTAL ASPECT OF THE GAME.
HE HELPED ME WITH MY SWING.
>> Raymond: IT WAS A FOCUS.
>> KEEP YOUR COOL.
I HAVE TO THROW GLOBAL
OCCASIONALLY.
I DON'T DO IT ANYMORE.
>> Raymond: DON'T DO IT TODAY,
NOT IN MY DIRECTION.
>> KEEP YOUR COMPOSURE.
>> IT IS MARKED THAT BRINGS ME
HERE.
HE DOES GREAT CHARITIES.
ANY CHARITY HE DOES I TRY TO GET
INVOLVED IF I CAN.
>> Raymond: I WOULD ONLY DO
THIS FOR YOU, OKAY?
THE TIP?
>> PICK UP TENNIS.
IF YOU HAVEN'T PLAYED FOR THAT
LONG, IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
GET THE GAME GOING.
>> Raymond: TELL ME WHAT THIS
FOUNDATION MEANS TO YOU.
I KNOW IT STARTED REALLY IS A
CALL FROM YOUR LOCAL PRIEST.
>> WE JUST WANT TO GIVE BACK TO
KIDS GROWING UP IN SIMILAR
SITUATIONS.
ALWAYS A FOCUS ON INNER-CITY
KIDS.
IT WOULD BE A SHAME FOR US NOT
TO UTILIZE THE PLATFORM ANYWAY
WE COULD.
OUR TIME, FINANCES.
>> Raymond: WHEN JIM CALLED ME
I SENT OUT TO BE A HAPPY -- I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO BE A GOFER.
HE SAID NO, A GOLFER.
I COULD HAVE BEEN AN ASSISTANT.
I'M GOING TO DESTROY THE GREENS.
>> THE GREAT THING IS TO KNOW
THAT WHEN I PLAY GOLF, I CAN'T
MAKE MONEY PLAYING GOLF SO I
JUST GO AND HAVE A GOOD TIME.
GO OUT AND HAVE FUN AND KEEP IT
IN PERSPECTIVE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
>> Raymond: CATCH YOU ON THE
GREENS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> Raymond: WELL, TO EVERY
LIFE AND EVERY GAME A LITTLE
RAIN MUST FALL SO HERE WE ARE
ABOUT TO GET INTO THE CART.
HERE ARE MY TEAMMATES.
MARY AND CHRIS AND AARON AND
ABIGAIL.
THESE FOUR PEOPLE, THEIR SCORE
IS GOING TO BE DROPPED TO LEVELS
UNSEEN HERE.
WE WILL HAVE A GOOD TIME, RIGHT?
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A GOOD
TIME.
WE ARE ON OUR WAY.
GREENS BEWARE.
I HAVE NOT PLAYED GOLF SINCE I
WAS 12 YEARS OLD.
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
>> Raymond: DON'T STATE WITH
SUCH SORROW AND PITY.
I DON'T NEED YOUR PITY.
>> KEEP YOUR KNEES BENT, YOUR
HEAD DOWN.
SLOW BACKSWING, SLOW
FOLLOW-THROUGH.
>> Raymond: FOLLOW ALL THE WAY
THROUGH.
>> YES.
>> Raymond: WILL TRY.
I JUST BRUISED THE GREEN.
THIS IS NOT GOOD.
SEND ALL THE RECEIPTS FOR THE
DAMAGED TURF TO MARK WAHLBERG.
LOS ANGELES, CALIFORNIA.
90210.
THANK YOU.
GOD.
I THINK I KILLED A RESIDENT OF
THE REST HOME NEXT DOOR.
I WAS ABOUT THAT CLOSE TO
HITTING THE WINDOW OF THAT
HOUSE.
I'VE GOT TO SAY, THIS IS VERY
GOOD THROUGH THE EGO OF THE
OTHER PEOPLE PLAYING.
I HAVE TO SAY I THINK MY
FAVORITE PART OF THIS WHOLE
EXPERIENCE IS RUNNING AROUND ON
THE CARTS.
WHICH I DO LOVE.
I THINK I COULD DO THIS ALL DAY.
OKAY, THIS IS TOO BIG.
THAT IS NOT THE PUTTER.
THAT'S ALL LOOKING.
DON'T LAUGH, IT'S NOTHING FUNNY
ABOUT THIS.
LOOK AT THAT BEAUTIFUL >> GOING
BY.
MY QUESTION IS HOW MANY MORE
HOLES DO WE HAVE?
IT'S A BANK SHOT, MARY.
STOP LAUGHING.
WHEN WE HER RETURNING THE COURT,
YOU'VE HEARD GUYS BREAKING WHER.
16 UNDER.
I AM 6 FEET UNDER AFTER THIS
EXPERIENCE BUT HONESTLY BEING
WITH ERIN AND CHRIS, MARY AND
ABIGAIL, THEY TAUGHT ME THE
FOUNDATIONS OF GOLF TODAY WHICH
I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR.
LOOK, TO HAVE DONE IT FOR AN
INCREDIBLE CAUSE FOR THESE
CHILDREN WHO WILL BENEFIT THANKS
TO THEM MARK WAHLBERG YOUTH
FOUNDATION, THAT MAKES IT ALL
WORTHWHILE.
ALL RIGHT, GIVE ME THE CLUBS.